great to meet y'all so listen let's jump
into it Darren I love this season I'm so
excited thank you and yeah you're
welcome and I feel like every season you
manage to just build on the last it's
incredible and I guess I'm curious as to
you know
I feel like we see a lot more of the
ensemble cast this season which is
amazing yes is there any character that
you know you want to dig a Little Deeper
with or you want to tell a bit more of
their backstory
well I think I wanted to do that with
all the characters this season and going
forward next season you know even more
so I think that's what's wonderful about
now that now that like we've seen you
know the show started with Emily on her
journey and it's expanded out to the
rest of this wonderful cast and um and
and and characters that you know I'm
also curious about knowing more about
them and and and
um and following and following their
stories and I think their stories all
begin to have a lot of complications
this season
yes they do
all right you do so Emily finds herself
you know this season debating whether
she's going to be working for Madeline
or Sylvie I got a question for you if
you had to choose one who would you work
for
wow I would um you know I understand
Emily's dilemma she wants to be loyal
you know you know it's sort of like you
know
um dance with the one who brought you
and I think that at the same time I
think she loves working with Sylvie and
I think she learned so much from her
experience working with Sylvie so she
has a tough choice on her hands mm-hmm
and Lucas what about you
have Choice um you know we're at the
premiere yesterday and and witnessing
all the audience cracking up to uh
Kate's instincts and nuances was really
made me want to work with her but at the
same time she's so chaotic and messy
that
um you would want to work with someone
with a bit more structure so it's you
know it's a ying and the young
it's like comparing LA and New York you
love them both for different reasons
it's very true that's very true okay
Lucas I gotta ask you if you were
picking between Gabriel and and Alfie
who should Emily end up with I gotta do
it I think Emily should make uh should
make should choose herself
um in not in the long run she should end
up with someone but she she should you
know as we say in France take a step
back to jump further she should maybe
you know reflect and uh and and be sure
of what she really months and what makes
sense for her I just want her to be
happy
oh that's beautiful I agree I want I
want to see Emily happy too I want to
see Emily happy always so Darren we've
we've seen such a transformation in
Emily you know
um can you ex you know explain a bit
about her emotional Journey from season
one to season three well I think season
one she comes to Paris
um you know in a very you know
unintentional way she doesn't speak
French she wasn't prepared for the job
but she has a lot of confidence in
herself and she's really good at her job
and she's she's
um she's really smart and her heart's in
the right place
um she makes a lot of faux pas season
one trying to sort of understand
navigate French culture but I think by
you know and and she grows in season two
she's taking French and by season three
I think she's so much more comfortable
living in Paris and it's starting to
feel like home to her and she's also
finding herself
um really functioning so well at work
finding you know actually being very you
know rather than being a nuisance at
work she's become a very important key
player there yes amazing the evolution
of Emily right yes that's amazing that
is amazing so what can fans expect what
can they get excited for for season
three give me a little tea
no spoilers it's a real roller coaster
and I think some amazing locations were
filming on the top of the Eiffel Tower
we're at the musee D'Orsay or say Museum
we are in Provence we're in Lower Valley
we're going up in hot air balloons we're
we're all over the map I can't believe
we went to so many different locations
how did we fit this in three months yeah
four months four months this is what I'm
wondering too I'm like okay first of all
where's my passport I need to go to
Paris you're taking a trip to uh to
France by watching this this yeah
absolutely absolutely you called it well
let's do this one in person next season
wonderful well thank you so much I
appreciate you and thank you so much for
this season yeah